leave it to Quentin Tarantino to open
one of his movies on Christmas Day go
out and have a wonderful seasonal time
with this one folks there's a lot of
blood in this movie Django Unchained
tells the tale of a slave played by
Jamie Foxx who's freed by a bounty
hunter played by Christoph Waltz
Christoph Waltz's character is looking
for a specific amount of people Django
knows what these people look like so he
can then lead Christoph Waltz to these
people so they can kill them and get the
money
this is appealing to Django because in
the movie he says kill white folk and
get paid for it what's not to like but
he also has something else driving him
his wife is also a slave and they were
separated and her owner is Leonardo
DiCaprio he runs this place in which
slaves fight to the death and Jamie Foxx
and Christoph Waltz tried to infiltrate
this business to see if they can free
Jamie Foxx's wife now this is a great
movie yes I am so happy to see a movie
like this this is an original movie as
usual Tarantino but it's a film that has
his trademark dialogue but you can't
expect things or certain things that are
staples yes they're all pretty much very
bloody you're probably gonna hear the
n-word a lot but in this film it doesn't
feel as gratuitous as it did in Jackie
Brown it has a vibe that Kill Bill had
that revenge vibe but it also has this
whole Western thing going on that is so
entertaining and completely over the top
in every way but its tongue in cheek and
it knows what it is it's self-aware and
it's hilarious at times it really is
really funny sometimes when Django
starts to get really into this idea of
revenge and he starts killing people and
everything you get these amazing
graceful shots of him just standing
there with the wind and it's so funny
but it's also really striking as a
visual and it's just so hilarious
sometimes this movie is really funny now
one of the things that Tarantino does
really well is he kind of plucks actors
out of obscurity and just puts them in
his movies and this one you have Don
Johnson as a plantation owner and he is
excellent in this movie I'm not even
kidding he's so good very funny
there is a incredible scene that I will
not spoil with these masks that's all
I'm gonna say it's so funny just goes
through this film for that scene alone
since inglorious basterds the only
really good Christoph Waltz performance
I've seen is in carnage it's so nice to
see him back under Tarantino's direction
he does an excellent job in this movie
and his performance is so entertaining
right from scene one when he comes on
you like this guy is gonna be good this
is gonna be something really fun and it
is as the movie progresses and you meet
Leonardo DiCaprio's character this is
the evilest most dark character he has
ever played I've never seen him play a
character just this debased and I was
really impressed with his performance I
think there are a lot of Oscar
nomination worthy performances in this
film particularly Christoph Waltz
Leonardo DiCaprio and guess who samuel
l.jackson is incredible in this movie he
is so good I would just I would be so
happy if he got a Best Supporting Actor
nomination I don't think it will happen
but he's so good in this movie I'm
telling you he plays his old broken-down
guy who works for Leonardo DiCaprio and
he has a sort of relationship with him
where he can kind of talk smack to Leo
DiCaprio and he's not gonna get anything
back because he's old and you know he's
decrepit and he's kind of hobbling
around on his cane but there are so many
funny moments that I do not want to
spoil with his character he just has
this constant look of total bewilderment
most of the time that is just
uproariously funny I love this character
in this movie I would love to see Samuel
Jackson get a nomination for this movie
the action in the film is very well
handled and very impressive and very
bloody thank the fight with the crazy
eighty-eights in Kill Bill blood blood
blood haven't mentioned a lot about
Jamie Foxx let's talk a little bit about
him see as the movie progresses from the
beginning he doesn't have that much
dialogue he's very silent and that's
true to what it would be like back then
because a lot of slaves were very just
they don't know or should I say
something now or where's my place here
unfortunately that's how it was back
then but as he continues to realize that
Christoph Waltz is giving him various
freedoms he comes into his own as a
character and he gives a great
performance it's very entertainment the
actor realize this movie is entertaining
if you go into this movie and be like
what's with all this over-the-top stuff
then you just didn't get it this is a
movie that is gleefully aware of itself
it knows what it's doing and it does it
well my only issue with the film is it
is a tad over long I think it overstayed
his welcome by maybe late
10-15 minutes overall Django Unchained
is an excellent film it's completely
original as usual although it borrows
elements from many things but all of
Tarantino's films do he's very publicly
acknowledged the fact that he does omage
is to many of his favorite films and
this is one of his better films
definitely check it out when it comes
out I'm gonna give Django Unchained and
a thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this and you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]